well first of all hi guys um how are you
doing right now I mean where we're safer
at home we're locked in our apartments
our homes you know honestly I wouldn't
be doing anything else otherwise I don't
think but it's the fact that I don't
have the choice to decline going out
yeah it's like it's driving me insane I
have to ask what the obvious are you
guys quarantined together so we actually
decided it's myself Maddie
Rudy and Drew and then one of our other
friends Elaine we've all quarantined
together we made a giant fort in the
living room we've been kind of every
night cooking meals together so we're
kind of making the best out of it we
have to get into that finale
you got survived this insane storm
otherwise when you first read that that
was kind of gonna be how things played
out what was your reaction we kind of
got the episodes in chunks so we'd be
shooting like Episode four and all of a
sudden we'd be at lunch and we'd get an
email with the next episode and we'd all
run to somebody's trailer and sit down
oh my god it's happening and so we kind
of had no idea till later in the season
and we watched it really oh yeah so yeah
I mean it's it's cool because obviously
you know depending on what happens it
leaves the entire world with Outer Banks
up to what could happen next which i
think is fun for not just us as actors
they'll have an opportunity to kind of
explore you know what could be and
obviously you know where we're going and
now so we know where the gold is so I
think it's an exciting time to kind of
give it to the world and say like what a
junkie instead we're really gonna get
into now we thought it was dark and
dirty just then but it's gonna get real
leaves the door open for some really
exciting stuff I think okay so I have to
ask you about those two guys in the boat
are they to be trusted the ones who sort
of come to John VIII and Sarah's rescue
oh are you talking about yeah yeah we
don't know I mean we don't know and so I
think it'll be interesting to see where
the relationship between John B and
Sarah and Laurens captain Lawrence goes
whether or not he is Chi can get just a
big question mark how mad is JJ's dad
gonna be about his boat not looking
forward to that conversation I'll tell
you that much we're out of town we're
just gonna send it straight avoids I
feel really guilty yeah let me just take
this chain great friend good friend
which is why I'm wondering your
characters had the opportunity to call
people and let them know that you're
safe
and they chose not to why not let the
friends know that yeah
I think our first reaction is because we
have no idea what's going on in the
world back there and what we could
potentially getting ourselves into and
then if we expose ourselves to this
captain all of a sudden there's a bounty
on my head so you have to remember that
in any shape way or form anybody who
wants some sort of money is gonna look
at that raise two kids they're kind of
sweet but a little bit extra cash sounds
a little better than having two kids on
my boat so I think for us it's more like
we we want to I think subconsciously but
the reality of the stakes and staying
alive and staying innocent you know
until Jhanvi finds a way to prove
himself innocent and this entire thing
has got us to remain anonymous he does
over the boat radio really put Sarah's
dad Ward on blast do you think there's
gonna be consequences for Ward I think
it will be that's one of my big
questions is what's gonna happen with
Cameron's because the Karen's are now
and not bit of a pickle all of these
little puppet strings that Ward has kind
of been playing are now kind of coming
loose and he doesn't really have control
over its world anymore I feel like there
definitely will be consequences for Ward
or Rafe maybe both so that'll be really
interesting to see how that plays out I
think it's interesting too because he's
so tied up at so many thing so like this
guy who was complete and total control
over the island for god knows how long
all of a sudden is potentially you know
John he's sold his soul like he's now in
this position to where you realize that
he's actually responsible for all the
chaos on and on so is she gonna pull a
ward move and completely get himself out
of this thing yet again and clear his
name or is he gonna do the responsible
conscious thing and take responsibility
for his actions and put his family in a
better position do you feel like Sarah's
relationship with her dad and her
brother are
are done like do you think those tides
are severed for good
as far as her relationship with ward
I don't think personally I would love
for there to be some sort of
confrontation what I love about Sarah
especially in season one you really see
her kind of come into her own and kind
of find her voice and come out from
under like umbrella that is like what
her dad has kind of created this world
and so I would love to have some sort of
confrontation with ward even though she
has chosen John me I do know there's a
part of Sarah that does still love him
very deeply and still does want to
protect him but she's very much aware
that he's not the person he's ever made
himself out to be I would love to see
them sit down and really get to the
bottom of why he's doing what he's doing
like what was his motive in this entire
reasoning besides being you know
obviously greedy for the gold and what
we've seen but as a father you know I
think there's always that fatherly
instinct to want to protect your family
so I think you do see that like I do you
think he you see his soft spots for you
know for Sarah and you know obviously
rose and Weezy rate was a little you
know there's a bit of a different
dynamic there peace you see he cares he
provides but the way he goes about her
very sketchy do you think that's
something that should be could be will
be explored in season two I mean have
the writers talk to you about the
direction that they think the show could
go it yeah we've had small conversations
about ideas or you know maybe like
potential you know directions for
storylines and they think obviously the
Cameron dynamic it is a big one because
I think that's a big question mark at
the end of season two like what's gonna
happen with this family that like this
golden this human that was once very
much the golden family and now it's just
unraveled completely I think that's
definitely something that's going to be
explored
I think raised my brother like what's
gonna happen with him and more how are
they going to potentially cover up a
murder is a big one
and
I think with you know with the potential
maybe return of Sarah to the Outer Banks
at some point how is that going to be
addressed yeah I think the big question
is that you know like obviously we have
these two kids who completely uprooted
their lives in a place where they would
have never imagined this type of stuff
to happen so are they gonna come back
you know am I still convicted felon in
my a convicted murderer I mean it's
beyond the murder at this point it's a
solo police car you know i salted people
I've evaded arrest I've done so many
things yeah and now she's in a compost
one charge is one thing but we're
looking at you know a vast majority of
different things that have happened over
the span of this you know this first
season so you know you have the Camerons
storyline that obviously we need to get
to the bottom of and is it I mean I
can't run forever and you know we going
and today's day and age you can you can
get away from the police for a minute
but after a while and then they're quick
we got some technology in today's day
and age so that was my next question is
do you think John B is gonna have to be
held accountable for his actions even
though they were done because he was
being wrongly accused of something it's
like there's two kind of sides of the
coin that's sure yeah I mean it's an
interesting an interesting way of
looking at it it's one of those things
to where like you see one thing go wrong
and then everything from there starts to
yeah domino effect so are you
responsible for your actions if your
actions align with something that
happened based on something that you
didn't do but I think in the court of
law you know there's a different set of
rules and there's a different way of
going about it so I'm interested to see
what other writers put together I mean
I'm excited to get back to that
headspace after we're all safe and sound
for this you know crisis right now and
to be able to get some content in our
hands and look at it I swear to God
board
I've come back one day I do also have to
ask you about the threat that he made
toward John be made towards saying like
I am gonna come back for you like I will
get what's mine like those are some like
fighting words it's like fighting words
right yeah I think I think first and
foremost junkies gotta work on his
fighting skills a little bit because
obviously you know early here at
lowliness think John V is one of those
kids who he sticks to his work like
throughout the entire season like his
kid does everything he says is gonna do
it whether it's figuring out where his
father it's figuring out the fold I mean
everything that he does he's 100%
committed so I'm excited to explore that
side of the character where you know
he's out for one thing and one thing on
and it's where then and it's you know to
put his father's name put some respect
on it and and I think that's an
incredible thing to put a young guy
through you know he's already gone
through hell and back so how much deeper
down Dante's Inferno are you gonna send
this kid before you can finally reach
you know some sort of sanity and how do
you think everything is gonna affect
John B and Sarah's relationship but
there's a season two it's like they've
been through so much yeah like get
stronger or you I think that's the big
question right - because I mean when you
look at the timeline they've only really
been together for a week right love
those star-crossed lovers but I think
it'll be interesting because you have
this fun like you know obviously we're
headed to the Bahamas now so you know
you have these two kids who are
obviously madly in love with each other
and they're headed to the Bahamas so it
feels like there's this great
opportunity to show like the honeymoon
phase of this relationship where they're
you know they run away from home and
they're in this vacation destination and
everything seems fine and then all of a
sudden just like the drama just hits Lee
they just think if everything catches up
to them yeah so I think they're done
I'm gonna go through some challenges I
think on the contrary of that - it's
like you have that potential reality and
then you have the reality of like it
could be Survivorman
you know the Bahamas in some places is
very developed and then in other places
you're kind of like yeah you've got a
coconut so it could be you know
either/or and I think the obvious
reality of it is like you're gonna have
to have something sort of both in the
world and to find that that balance
between shots - I mean at the end of the
day like we are now officially on the
bond the love got to be there the trust
has got to be there and is this
relationship going to survive all of
these things have we established were
you guys to post a film in the Bahamas
in order to not exploit you know any any
anyone's home any countries obviously
very cautious about how we go about it
comes in the Caribbean go back what it
lost us the past few years and things
are you guys ready for people to ship
you two together because we know with
Netflix why it shows that tends to
happen no I mean I think the thing is is
with this quarantine going on right now
like it's so hard to actually grasp
reality we can't stay yeah review so I
think it's one of those things where you
know like the vm's have started people
started to kind of reach out seeing a
little bit of things happening on online
but it's super exciting it's really cool
you know to obviously see people
attached to something
Maddie and I thought that is a lot of an
honest authentic take on what it should
be like to be in a young relationship
what a healthy two-way relationship
looks like I really wanted like you know
like fully consensual your minds in it
here your hearts in it I mean that was
something that we talked about early on
just making sure that that was very
clear yeah and then three things that
you really want to see happen in season
two I wouldn't see some action some more
action I really want Sarah to get in on
it I kind of want her to be I want to
see some sort of confrontation with the
Camerons I don't want to see them butt
heads
I don't see the folks for you know I
want to see John B figure out a way to
clear his name completely and I want to
see how how and where Jada being Sarah
go and is this something that is
sustainable or is this something that
they're both in over their heads
and the fact that I'm going to either of
us know right now and Jenna's Josh and
Shannon are like we know is painstaking
because we're sitting in quarantine so
hopefully we'll find out soon about the
answers yeah yours were a good to you
come on good they were great
[Music]